foreign
everybody knows that Rihanna has big
fits how big are they together big it's
a biggest this is our opinion as
qualified experts I'm glad you dialed
you and I'm Josh pascowitz we're about
to see we're about to see this pink
so we're at the Fenty Beauty and skin
launch so it only makes sense that
Rihanna's showing a little bit more skin
Rihanna is wearing the attico halter top
the bottoms are also from attico and the
shoes are just a pair of platform
sandals diamond and Amethyst drop
earrings and a matching bracelet there's
a real dichotomy though because Rocky's
wearing a Louis Vuitton letterman jacket
purple matching t-shirt the jeans are so
destroyed we can't identify them and the
sneakers again are Louis Vuitton also
the Yankees cap with Care Bears that
looks like Care Bears a little looks
like aliens a little bit Care Bear
aliens carabarians maybe carabarians
okay he's obviously wearing a very nice
Varsity from one of Virgil's last
collections okay you know it's beautiful
materials you know that the sneakers are
expensive there's that difference
between like dressed up and expensively
dressed yeah I don't know how you feel
about this but I'm not necessarily one
that says couple should match but the
green LV sneaker others to Rihanna's top
at least gives it a little bit of
coherence while they're posing for the
pictures if we switched out the jeans
for something a little bit more clean
clean yes then all of a sudden it's an
equal playing field yeah maybe even
white jeans
I think they match each other's energy
in different ways she's a little
dressier he's a little casual that's the
intangible the intangible part of the
fit which is what helps it be big in a
lot of cases yeah we have to see what
else is happening
[Music]
where do you think it goes
the lowest fit the big fit still a big
fit still a big fit couples fit yeah
exactly I think one fit I'll shine the
other yeah
so this isn't just a day out on the town
although that's kind of the vibe they
are actually shooting a music video
Rihanna's top is by Dolce Gabbana it's a
corset from Spring 2005. it's a luiva
shearling coat lace-up trousers from
giacomas the shoes are Amina mawadi
pumps she's got this head scarf maybe
vintage on the other end of Rihanna's
hand we have Rocky wearing an all-black
Stefan cook set it's the jeans and the
jacket quilted denim jacket has sort of
a racer vibe to it wearing a lux old
Moto boot from over here looks like it
could be Prada but indeterminate
designer I think the all black is fly I
think the fit of the pants great jacket
great the belt I think is dumbfly too I
mean the quilting the cross hatching it
gives it a Motocross kind of feel which
is accentuated by the boots it's the
crop of the jacket is what really does
it for me because the pant is relatively
slim it's got a high waist you want to
accentuate that by the crop of the
jacket the Hardware on the snaps goes
back to the Belt goes back to the
jewelry goes back to the teeth yep big
block big big big feet this is a big fit
and in relation to Rihanna's fit which
is equally big floor length shearling
yeah is that a snake skin on the bustier
what is that oh wow crazy 95s you have
the gold herringbone and I think they
match each other's energy it's crazy
it's just an amazing ring too he also
has with the ring some big Ruffles
potato chips right there which is a nice
accessory now if I was gonna say
anything if I wanted to naysay anything
at all yep don't love love love the
trucker hat I agree with you I would
take away the trucker hat so I would say
I wear a trucker hat every day and I
think this trucker hat is just the wrong
trucker hat maybe if it was sitting a
little higher if we've seen a little
higher on the crown like the way you
wear yours exactly yeah exactly but
still very very big
foreign
out of your hand okay and uh
that's a bull move I'm a bold person
that's kind of a big fit dude it's a
very big fish and it's a big combo it's
a big call to make so early on I'm ready
to take that chance okay let's see let's
see though okay let's see
okay it's looking kind of big okay look
three is from the 2021 Met Gala Rihanna
is wearing valenciaga Couture and a
beanie cap you know which definitely
brings it back down to earth a little
bit I didn't even notice I mean the
beanie really sets it off asap's wearing
a custom erl suit and a vintage quilt to
show up on the carpet with the blanket
slash quilt wrapped around you like that
is a major major move apparently this
quilt was donated to a thrift store and
erl founded and Incorporated it into
this look for Rocky I mean the fact that
this thing came fully fashioned like
that and just threw it on top is kind of
a stroke of Genius yeah the volume of it
then matches what Rihanna's wearing I
mean obviously the underneath is much
more formal but he's Still rocking it in
a casual way the ruffle shirt is on top
the pants are a little bit longer yeah I
think the idea of it was kind of like a
Cheesy prom tuxedo right and does a good
job of balancing that out and making it
Fly we got the pearls we've got the
brooch normally I would never recommend
wearing an untucked button front shirt
with a Blazer yeah in this set of
circumstances because it's Rocky because
of the pearls because of the Ruffles
wearing it out is okay for me also the
jacket's a little cropped yeah also
there are rules to be broken as long as
stylistically you know the rules you got
to know the rules to break the rules no
you have to be fly to break the rules
and get away with it that's the real
deal and so all that kind of has this
cheesy kind of thing like definitely 80s
prom Dumb and Dumber or whatever like
the little ruffle shirts and then you've
got Rihanna who's wearing this
voluminous coat yeah obviously the
jewelry is Mega and then she's got her
little beanie on it brings the looks
together as far as I'm concerned and it
makes it it modernizes it and it makes
it Rihanna you know Rihanna's an
innovator
[Music]
foreign
's more casual one's more dressy but
your man is wearing a quilt this is in
the right place so far there could be a
contest between those two okay but let's
see I'm still not over yet
okay okay so this is the fall 22 Gucci
Adidas presentation in Milan Rihanna's
wearing a Gucci latex and lace top satin
trousers with that Dragon print and a
silver chain male hat and who can miss
the Gucci faux fur coat covering it all
Rocky's wearing a Gucci jacket and top
the bottoms are Gucci as well the Adidas
Gucci gloves a Gucci monogram briefcase
and the sneakers are Adidas and Gucci I
see a little Gucci let's start with
Rihanna okay head gears killer I like
that I like our headgear and this fur
when I first saw this I kind of didn't
notice this because you know mother to
be I looked at the headgear and I looked
at the belly and the dragon on the pants
and there's a lot of different textures
going on here you've got the lace as
part of the sort of belly top yeah a
little patent leather patent leather
going on there then you got the satin
the satin Dragon yeah and you know the
headpiece and the necklace feel very
deco yeah you know whereas you have the
fur and a lavender seven years old right
but anything but 70s and then the sheen
was a re of the Dragon which is very
like 70s 80s into the dragon yeah so
she's like on multiple different decades
right here but she's able to pull it all
off and in relation to me there's a
little bit of a disjointed thing going
on between his outfit and his
accessories you know she's got a lot of
different errors and a lot of different
things going on it ends up feeling
balanced because it's so busy yeah
whereas the thing that really grabs
attention on what Rocky's wearing is the
release and the gloves I like the
leather pants I like it's easy I mean
it's just a little bomber a little
leather pants yeah I mean what more do
you need really
foreign
I'm gonna go ahead and agree see that
you know in some ways I think that this
is a Zone
this is a Zone one person's fit is
outshining another's over here whereas
two kids are equally big over here
this is the last one damn
okay so in 2019 we're in London for the
fashion awards Rihanna is wearing head
to toe Fenty and matching gloves back to
her jacket Rocky also is wearing Fenty
appropriately it's a black tuxedo from
the fashion show of that year and his
sneakers are from Rick Owens the dress
is definitely giving me prom Vibes it's
satin it's Fenty the gloves that you can
see the Rings through I like that they
are both rocking braids yep it helps
bring the looks together in my opinion
yeah I like the shoes she's matching to
it t if you talk about monochromatic
we've got multiple different textures
yeah I like the contrast between quote
unquote Tiffany blue and the black of
his look hold on hold on we have to
point out them diamonds shine bright
like a diamond is that whole choker
Diamond I think it might be damn but it
might be so Rocky's wearing Fenty also
which is not known to make menswear and
didn't for very long and I think that
there might be a reason why let's talk
about what I like about the look first
okay the satin lapels with the buttons
that are not covered I think is a nice
way to keep it a little bit more casual
you can tell that the jacket is padded
you can tell that the pants are also
padded could be fill like a primaloft
kind of pill almost like like a thin
down material what that does is make it
almost look like a ski suit in a way
because you do need that right you need
that insulation and it also makes the
jacket less of a Blazer and more of a
coat when you have that kind of feel and
it also looks like it could be a little
hot yeah he's cooking I would be cooking
in there
yeah keep those lights all the time keep
those lights on sunshine I don't really
like the fit of the suit but I
especially don't like the fit of the
pants I agree and disagree I love an
oversized suit this kind of misses the
mark when you're wearing like an
oversized suit that has like a minimum
construction and has like a flow or a
drink to it the padding because I
actually don't mind the pens okay it's
it's the jacket that's bothering me
slightly if you're gonna have a Blazer
this big I think the shoulders should
have a little more structure I think it
changes the energy of it and I think the
shoes are good shoes are great here's a
question for you would it make a
difference if the jacket was a little
bit shorter nope he looks good he's got
confidence so like in terms of whether
or not we have quibbles with the look
yeah he's doing his thing he's certainly
there to like be a partner and they look
amazing and they look great together and
you have enough coordination with the
satin that it makes it feel like it's
very much on purpose yeah I'm not mad at
it but I don't think it's the biggest
foreign
this fit is the most equal of these
three fits which makes it in my opinion
the middle fit yeah but let me know what
you think I agree I think we got this
big fit right I'm gonna say I feel like
they're more in sync on the right and
that's why those fits are leading
because we are here to talk about
couples fits couples fit don't be
judging individually two plus two
is not the right math one plus one plus
one equals two and in some cases it
equals three